[Music]
a professor of Princess just discovered
the limits of academic freedom the
fragile feelings of students as part of
a lesson on free speech in an
anthropology class professor called
lawrence rosen asked students whether it
was worse for a white man to physically
attack a black man or to use a racial
slur students didn't react well when he
stormed out at least one got right in
his face and screamed the f-word rosen
has now cancelled his class [ __ ] senior
political analyst britt hume went to
college when it was different
joins us now wi-wo' but but what I found
so striking about this was this class
was up this not something he just threw
out there this class was about speech
what speeches offense it was
anthropology class how odd is it that
Princeton students couldn't handle it
well we're talking here about the about
the N word which is one of the ugliest
words in the language and for sure and
we don't go around using it for that
reason and yes and it's offensive
however I would submit that there is a
difference between using the word and
mentioning the word there's a difference
between using the word that is to say
calling someone that or speaking of
others in using that word saying that
they are you know that and mentioning
and discussing the word and then a class
devoted to this very subject of you know
language and what's offensive and what's
not you ought to be able to mention the
word and in so doing say the word after
all he didn't the professor wasn't
calling anybody by that name he was
simply discussing the word itself and
that's a distinction that seems to me
has been lost in this in this in this
absolute wave of political correctness
in which think some things are simply
now unsayable yes and it make to me it
makes no sense I mean I like most people
I hate that word and I don't want to
hear it but I also would like to think
the Princeton students would be rational
enough that if you sit and look we're
having a discussion about speech and
violence in his speech ever violence for
example and this is a horrible thing to
say but here it is that they will be
able to track with that and they'd be
smart enough to kind of understand what
you were saying but they don't seem like
they were know and I think that you know
that there
one of the problems here tucker is that
you know America is a compassionate
country and a country that strives for
justice and equality and we want to be
sensitive to other people's feelings
yeah and therefore if you're a victim in
any of these areas it's kind of a good
deal you get a lot of consideration you
get a lot of sympathy and it seems to me
that we've reached the stage in America
where we have people who are basically
going around applying for victim status
or seeking to be offended so they can
react to it and be indignant and you
know even DLF bombs at the college
professors and I sense that it's utterly
regrettable and you see these the
sensitivity going on all the time I mean
this is what we mean we talk about a
little snowflakes our colleague Fox News
contributor guy Benson ran into
resistance up at Brown University
another Ivy where people said it was
offensive and long for him to be
permitted to speak there this is all
part of the same phenomenon and it is
very widespread it is very disturbing
it's been widely reported on and I think
most people in America disapprove of
this and yet on it goes and the
responsibility seems to me falls upon
these university administrators and the
faculty which put up with this crap and
have for a long time and this needs to
stop in a letter at Brown they accused
two guy benders probably the nicest guy
in the building of enabling white
supremacy which isn't say in in the
twenty seconds we have if you had an 18
year old right now would you be worried
about sending that child to college well
I have an 18 year old granddaughter who
is at college and I'm pleased to say
that there hasn't been many reports at
the college where she's going of this
kind of stuff going on but it very much
concerns me and yeah III am concerned
about it and I and I got another
granddaughter coming along in a couple
of years will be headed off to college
and I very much hope that she will
choose a college and will be able to get
into a college where there's a minimum
of this kind of stuff going on but more
than that Tucker I hope that by that
time that this that this attitudes about
this will change and the eschatology
administrators will begin to grow some
backbone I hope so the revolutional it
burned itself out Britt thank you very
much
you've got to see you